Scripts are strongly connected to current theories of human cognition.
In fact one recent theory says that brain is a predictable machine. We do
very quick bottom up processing followed by mostly top down processing with
general expectations of the world. Then we act on those expectations. This idea
in fact is so strong, that when it fails it leads to amusement, or surprise, or
anger. If I violate the expectations of your script, you might find it funny or
surprising or you might be upset about it. An interesting and open question is,
whether we carry the scripts in our hear or do we generate them at run time?
Scripts are also current with the notion of mental models. You and
I have mental models, or scripts. Not just about social situations like going to
a restaurant, going to a movie, but also about how the computer program works,
how the economy works, how the car engine works, your physical, social, economic
works. Note that scripts can be culture specific. In the U.S. for example,
going to a restaurant typically involves leaving a tip. But in many countries,
this is not the case. In fact in some countries, tipping is considered
insulting. So scripts presumably evolved through cultural interaction over long
periods of time. But once there, they're a very powerful source of knowledge.